ah yeah today i'm going to share my
favorite tips to learn languages with
music this topic is definitely my jam
and i have lots of experience with it
songs are one of my favorite language
learning tools as you will see in this
lesson
they can be a fun and playful way to
learn english
so if you watch until the end you will
get 4 fun tips and activities
that you can do with songs that will
help you to
make sense of grammatical structures to
expand your vocabulary
and even improve your pronunciation and
of course
to increase your fluency so turn the
volume up and let's do this
and by the way if you are new here every
week we help you to understand
fast speaking natives without getting
lost without missing the jokes
and without subtitles just like danielle
whose understanding is getting better
lesson by
lesson we're going to take your
comprehension to the next level too
just hit that subscribe button and the
button below and you won't miss a single
one of our new lessons
so first off they can help you to make
sense of grammar
you don't need to depend only on books
to learn grammatical rules
songs can also be a fun way to learn or
review grammar
it helps you to learn the conjugations
and master verb tenses
as they are often repeated over and over
again in different
songs also they are a great way to
recall the grammar that you have
already learned you can spot a certain
conditional sentence
or a relative clause for example so
here's one activity to use a song to
help you with your grammar
so first off you're going to choose a
song that you're already quite familiar
with
and a verb tense that you feel like you
need to master
so for example you might choose the
simple past or the part of simple form
then you will get the lyrics of your
chosen song and identify
all the verbs i might even highlight
them with a certain color for example
this step alone is already a great
exercise
but let's take it a step further so now
change all of them to the simple past
at this moment you're practicing
repeating the form so don't mind if the
lyrics turn out to be a little bit
strange
alternate between singing the song with
the original verbs and the changed verbs
a couple of times
you'll see that it'll help you to
remember them much more easily
and you can do the very same activity
with pretty much any word family
and you can even change adjectives to
adverbs or add prefixes or suffixes to
nouns
play with the opposites of adjectives
and so on
this might even get you laughing as you
will get a pretty silly
new version of the song
the music is really great for expanding
your vocabulary music is a really
powerful workout for your brain
as it activates both sides at the same
time
helping increase learning and memory
take for example that it's mainly
through songs
that kids learn their first pieces of
vocabulary just think about it
the abc's parts of the body colors
actions
there are songs for all of these that we
learn at an early age
songs will help you expand your
vocabulary too it's not for nothing that
bob dylan
a musician won the nobel prize in
literature for his poetic expressions
through music
one of the many good things about
learning new words with songs
is the fact that they are presented in
context so you don't learn isolated
items
but rather a particular meaning of a
word moreover
oftentimes you won't even need to look
up the word in the dictionary
and will be able to understand it
because of the context the words that
come before
or even the overall tone of the song
develop a habit of adding the words you
learned to your lexical book
or vocabulary apps like anki quizlet or
memrise
and revisiting them from time to time
also remember to put them into use
as soon as you learn them whenever
possible so a great exercise for you to
start doing this right now
is training with the lyrics one type of
lyrics training is an exercise in which
you need to fill in the blanks of a song
so there are two ways to go about it
first is by using the app or website
called lyrics training
or finding song activities on
coolenglish.net
in these websites the words you'll need
to identify and remember
are already chosen for you although you
can choose the level of difficulty
whether easy medium or hard so it's
great whether you're a beginner or
more advanced what's more it's a good
way to practice both listening
and vocabulary at the same time the
other way is to use the principle of
lyrics training to help you learn
through space repetition
which is a way of learning in which you
take the information that you need to
memorize
and repeat it across increasing
intervals you get the lyrics of the song
choose words that are new to you or that
you have a hard time remembering
and then you take them out of the song
anytime that they appear after that
you play the song and try to listen and
complete it with those words
after a while you may increase the
challenge and try to remember the words
before listening the song
this is a great way to train your
ability to recall words adding them to
your active vocabulary plus it's such a
fun challenge
the key here is to do that at intervals
just like you would with an app like
anki or memrise
so for example you do it first once
every day
then every two days then once a week
that way you're
forced to remember those words from time
to time and will be much more unlikely
that you will forget them once you've
done this with a few songs you can just
change the song you work with on each
day
and will only take you a few minutes and
i have a question
do you usually get frustrated when you
can't think of the right word
if you're like most learners i'm sure
you have emphatically said
yes well i have two suggestions for you
first check out our free
master class in it you will learn the
three keys to being able to understand
natives at
any speed first is vocabulary you will
learn the vocabulary that we need is
really used in our everyday speech and
we will help you to
never forget it second is pronunciation
you will understand and even be able to
imitate how we cut
and connect our words third is cultural
context
so you will be able to laugh along with
all the jokes
but you will not find this masterclass
on youtube to get exclusive access
you need to click up here or in the
description below to sign up for
free see you there and the second
suggestion is to check out this lesson
that andrea made on our other channel
about how to think in english you will
also find a link to that in the
description
and it's a great lesson to watch next
when it comes down to it language is
music
every language has its own rhythm so if
you speak english with the rhythm of
your native language
it can make you sound a little bit
unnatural songs tend to
exaggerate the rhythm of the language so
they can be a great tool to help you to
practice speaking english
with the correct rhythm and flow while
stressing words correctly
of course because of the melody in some
songs there might be a slight change in
the pronunciation
this is however the exception so it
should not scare you away from learning
with songs
most of the time words that rhyme fall
on the same beat
or post of the song and this certainly
helps you to identify patterns
on how to pronounce such words it is
also helpful for you to learn how to
actually pronounce a word
sometimes we learn words by reading and
we don't know how to pronounce them
or even worse we get bad habits of
pronouncing them incorrectly
songs will help you with that in a
natural and enjoyable way
another thing that songs aren't rich
with is connected speech and they will
help you to notice
which words are commonly reduced and
linked together
one of the benefits of using songs to
study is accent reduction
have you ever noticed how singers with a
very strong british accent like adele or
at sheeran
sound kind of american when they sing
this happens because accents are
distinguished based on the use of
intonation
vowel length articulation and so on
however
when a person sings these aspects are
neutralized
as the air flows and the articulation
and length of syllables and sounds tend
to become less precise
what's more the muscles being
articulated to project the
voice of a particular genre let's say
pop music
tend to share the same features of a
neutral american accent
so say you can sort of take your mouth
to the gym because it uses all the parts
of your body to produce sound
and helps you exaggerate the difficult
phonemes in english
that don't exist in your native tongue a
good exercise to practice pronunciation
inspired by the mimic method is to first
try to imitate the sounds you hear in
the song
without caring about the lyrics just say
random invented words
also known as gibberish in the same
rhythm and
melody of the song if possible identify
when a word is
emphasized when a sound rises and how
many sounds there are in a sentence
this will help warm up the muscles so
when you actually pronounce the real
words of the lyrics
they fall into place more comfortably
so if you still aren't convinced about
the benefits of songs for learning
english let me give you a final reason
music is
bound to help your fluency in general as
i mentioned
music has been one of my number one
language learning tools
in most of the six languages i have
learned i created playlists and spotify
for each language
i might listen to my french playlist
while cooking or catalan playlist while
working
by singing along i noticed huge
differences in my naturalness of my
speech when i got into conversations
why is this well first because music
affects our mood
and it can help to create a better
atmosphere for learning it might sound
silly
but having the right mindset does
wonders for our motivation
which sounds better to you studying
lyrics or studying grammar books
second when we like a song we tend to
stick with it for a while
listening to it on repeat non-stop
repetition
even from a passive perspective is an
extremely effective way of increasing
memorization
you can use melodies that you already
know or that are stuck in your head and
change the lyrics
invent your own story for the song
invent the meaning of everything that's
being said
you can create movements to words in the
song but the most important thing is to
sing
along enjoy the moment sing out loud
be it in your car on the way to work in
the shower or my favorite while cooking
dinner
if you want to take it to the next level
try this download a program like
audacity which is free
to edit audio cut the song into small
pieces
even just a few seconds choose
especially the parts that you find most
challenging to imitate
listen to these bits over and over again
once you feel comfortable identifying
what's being said sing those small bits
think of it like reps with a dumbbell
that you'd use to make your arms
stronger
but for your muscles of articulation if
this is difficult
you can also start by slowing down the
audio
then once you get more comfortable speed
it up this will help you speak
english faster if you want a good
challenge check out how we broke down
eminem's
song lose yourself in this lesson by
trying this exercise and others that
we've mentioned today
before you know it you're going to be
speaking english clearly and
naturally ah yeah
so to wrap up this lesson i have some
lightning recommendations for you
that will make all this much more fun
and easier
so first off start with songs that you
like but that are suitable for learning
and for your level don't choose a song
just because a teacher told you that
it's a good one
if you don't like it otherwise you will
not be motivated and you'll probably
give up
if you need some help finding a song a
great place to start
is with our playlist of lessons with
songs you can find navigating up here
or also down in the description below
and make sure you have access to the
lyrics
i really like genius lyrics because you
can also see information
about what the song is about and
sometimes this can help you to
understand the cultural context of them
as a bonus print them out take notes
mark them up
use colors be creative you can mix
active listening activities
like the exercise we mentioned with
passive listening that is listening for
pleasure
as confucius once said music produces a
kind of pleasure
which human nature cannot do without so
that said
enjoy it to the fullest and always be
learning now it's time to go beyond the
classroom and
live your english ah yeah
what's up everyone can you understand tv
shows and movies with subtitles in
english
but find it difficult to understand then
when you turn off the subtitles
don't worry you're not alone lots of
people get stuck
at this stage their vocabulary allows
them to understand media
through reading subtitles but their
listening skills
aren't quite there yet